[Musica]
personalmente devo dire che amo molto a
dormire
amo fare quel passaggio e o in un altro
mondo a sognare ma quello che amo di più
e poi risvegliarmi già con delle idee
che ho preso dal sogno il sogno che
enormente apre nuove porte mi confronto
con nuove possibilità come si può
guadare una vita come si può riflettere
la prossima la situazione e quindi a
risvegliarsi per me vuol dire mettersi
in movimento decidere qual è la strada
del prossimo giorno orientarsi
orientarsi verso il nuovo non sulla
strada di ogni giorno quindi di cercare
un po dove la porta nuova aperta dove la
strada che mi porta ad un 9 obiettivo è
quello vuol dire anche decidere tra le
tante possibilità che offre un nuovo
giorno dopo aver dormito bene
naturalmente aprire le porte aprirsi a
nuove idee aprirsi al mondo aprirsi alla
creatività questo è un po il mio scopo
di vita
poi non andare solo alla mia persona
perché io posso fare quasi tutto posso
fare il creativo ma uno scopo sociale
solo se le idee saranno partecipate che
tanti altri partecipano a quello che hai
sviluppato siamo a mantova parliamo di
una città che per decenni è stato la
bella addormentata
dormire bene va bene ma può essere anche
troppo è bella bellezza vuol dire anche
bella
ma per chi per pochi per molti per
troppi patati quando sono stato chiamato
a dirigere il complesso più grande e
complesso museale palazzo ducale di
mantova equa incita gli ho detto no io
non faccio il principe a baciare quella
bella addormentata
io mi rivolgo ai professionisti in campo
cioè i creativi e questi sono gli
artisti sono gli artisti contemporanei e
che lavorano ogni giorno sulla
creatività a mantova abbiamo l'esempio
più forte abbiamo cosi una parola magica
che si chiama gonzaga la famiglia che ha
fatto dal piccolo mantovana mantova alla
grande qui una veduta nella nostra la
nostra camera degli sposi molto famosa
camera picta perché proprio dipinto come
un unico nuovo modo di della creatività
questa famiglia gonzaga per oltre due
secoli ha puntato sempre sulla
creatività ha portato sempre le nuove
idee
era sempre al corrente che cosa è
l'ultima moda sabella d'este come una
grande style icon del suo tempo
sempre nuovi artisti si puntava su
pisanello grande disegno sul muro una
nuova idea rivoluzionaria andrea
mantegna giuliano amato sono tanti da
citare ma bisogna capire che tutti
questi artisti che adesso noi facciamo
così a grandi grandi maestri nel loro
tempo erano contemporanei e anche molto
discussi anche come straniere a rubens
per esempio un fiammingo italiano è
quindi non è che tutti l'hanno accettato
subito anche monteverdi e uno da cremona
poi è diventato il grande monteverdi a
mantova per poi morire a venezia ecco di
questo è un altro capitolo
quindi non si può risvegliare una città
con l'arte mantova è l'esempio più bello
perché quello che hanno capito subito di
con saga che quello che resta è
l'immagine quello che dà proprio la
forza molto a lungo tempo e l'immagine e
la composizione il coinvolgimento nell
immagine parliamo un po di altre città
conoscenti tutto questo è il museo più
visitato in italia si chiama uffizi che
vuoi dire non è nato come museo è nato
come un'architettura della burocrazia
sono uffizi che hanno fatto qua solo
calari a di questo stabilimento hanno
esposto un po dei quadri e poi man mano
altri quadri anche negli altri piani e
gli uffizi nel corso del tempo sono
diventato museo grazie ad una decisione
di puntare proprio sull'arte e di creare
un ambiente che oggi uno dei luoghi più
visitati
prendiamo un altro esempio
roma anche conosciuto l'anfiteatro più
grande cioè ma immaginare per secoli
questo anfiteatro così grande è stato
semplicemente un deposito è stato usato
diciamo negozi o gratis per cantieri di
palazzi attuali e poi ad un certo punto
si è deciso no dai
attenzione dobbiamo prendere cura di
questo dobbiamo rivalutare dobbiamo
risvegliare questo monumento perché è
proprio il centro dell'antico roma
quindi parla di una città che molto più
grande che la città nella quale viviamo
adesso oggi il colosseo come sapete uno
dei monumenti più visitati in tutta
l'italia in tutto il mondo
altro esempio venezia venezia rende alla
fine del settecento era proprio il
casinò d'europa si potrebbe dire anche
il casinò d'europa
vietato ai minorenni perché era una
città un po vicino al peccato solo poi
dopo man mano anche qui si puntava più
sull'arte si parlava di più non sul
gioco d'azzardo ma si parlava più di
tiziano tintoretto
ma questo non bastava per i veneziani
che erano sempre molto legato all'inter
nazionale hanno creato una idea favolosa
1895 la prima biennale biennale d'arte
non del passato dell'arte contemporanea
quindi un confronto diretto in una città
quasi museale ogni due anni
questo concetto adesso viviamo nostra
esperienza quest'anno tanti che vengono
tanti che proprio qui hanno il luogo
d'incontro per confrontarsi con la
creatività attuale bellissima idea
grande successo
speriamo di un altro loro numeri di loro
come sapete è stato la dimora dei re
della francia poi diciamo il centro del
potere
la rivoluzione francese ha cambiato
completamente hanno deciso non abbiamo
più re ma facciamo di questo palazzo
un museo per tutti i cittadini che hanno
il diritto di
avvicinarsi alla creatività del passato
lungo periodo lungo museo e poi un po di
crisi anche perché tutto un po
tradizionale e si pensato ma che cosa
possiamo fare per diciamo fare un nuovo
passo verso la nostra vita attuale e
hanno creato questa piramide questo
intervento del architettura
contemporanea che ha dato un altro
centro d'attenzione non solo spaziale ma
anche spirituale per questo centro
oggi come sapete il loro è il luogo più
visitato il museo più visitato tutto il
mondo dovete immaginare l'austria a
circa 8 milioni abitanti tine abitanti
dell'austria vengono a visitare il
louvre ogni anno parliamo di londra
anche una città grandissimo tanti
problemi non si sa nemmeno quante
abitanti ci sono tanti lodi anche i
poetici insieme come un grande museo
tradizionale ma ha perso un po il filo
con la gioventù e quindi si è creato la
take moda e non sia affatto un nuovo
moser ha anzi si è appreso una struttura
già esistente trasformandola in un museo
d'arte contemporanea e adesso tutti
giovani vengono proprio a visitare
questo stabilimento giovani d'età ma
anche di cervello di avere preghiamo di
barcelona anche una città molto
interessante molto diciamo con tanti
ritmi i problemi quando hanno parlato di
fare un nuovo museo per l'arte
contemporanea non l'hanno messo nella
piazza sulla piazza più prestigiosa e
l'hanno preso e l'hanno portato e creato
proprio in un ambiente molto
problematico con un articolo sociale
conobbi chiaramente e con questo
investimento tutto tutti i problemi ma
tanti problemi sono stati risolti e poi
da citare naturalmente sempre l'effetto
bilbao
io ho visitato bilbao e posso dire
proprio che non è stato una città molto
bello anzi non vogliamo perdere alcuni
parole ma questa idea geniale di far
portare un museo con grande nome di
guggenheim proprio in città
puoi creare un'architettura che per sé
già un punto d'attrazione ha cambiato
tutta la vita in città
se andate oggi a bilbao vedete non solo
turisti ma vedete anche una città
risvegliata del tutto bellissima ultimo
pensiero mio
adesso abbiamo capito che si può
risvegliare con l'arte ogni giorno anche
alla grande alla piccola ma quello che
vorrei darvi un po come il messaggio che
questo è un vostro diritto quando hanno
fatto i diritti universali umani dopo
tutta la crudeltà della seconda guerra
mondiale hanno messo anche l'articolo 27
potete leggerlo è un diritto di noi di
partecipare di avere accesso alla
contemporaneità deve accesso alla
creatività quindi risvegliamoci in
questo senso grazie
[Applauso]